check out this video this is from the Dr
Phil show it's a fifth grade teacher so
he's just a fifth grade teacher this guy
trying to explain basic biology to
several trans activists and watch how it
goes transgender boys who might not have
their own money to go buy tampons if
they're provided free in the bathroom
it's it's a huge plus men do not
menstruate only women men straight now
you can call yourself whatever you want
straight but trans men do menstrual
non-binary people only women reading is
not exclusive yes it is women no it's
not yes it is
if your Columbus homes are xx and you're
young you menstruate if you're XY you
don't correct but what about trans men
and non-violence we're not putting a
whole group they're women dressed as men
you are not a man you pretend to be a
man and that's okay that's perfectly
fine live your life tell me what a man
is well what's a man to you you define a
man for me you have chromosome terms
that are X and Y that's what a man is so
why are we just looking at the the the
the science of this as an assignment
when when we've learned sex and gender
identity a two very the completely
different thing they're not completely
different they are completely different
completely different words and this is
what you're born with the sexual
reproductive organs you have gender is
what you identify with well I don't
accept that distinction you have to
argue for it you're just giving a
conclusion you're you're just making it
up people the people who hate the truth
people who hate the truth are because
they see they see the truth as hateful
if you want to identify in any way you
can you're free to do so but that does
not mean that the rest of us have to
join that illusion you disagree I
disagree with you and so you call it
hate but there's no hate in my heart at
all so that's you are being hateful when
you tell somebody that identifies as a
man that they're not a man that's
hateful that's a fact I have to say
that's the third time I've watched that
video today and that teacher Ray can we
can we find him I'd love to have him on
because what a what a calm decent
explainer of the truth and you know it's
funny you know I always say this thing
about how when you're telling the truth
you don't have to be screaming and you
can sort of tell it in people's body
languages because you can just
communicate it honestly without being
hysterical and everything even the way
he's kind of sitting there like well you
guys have come to the conclusion it's
not reality but you've come to that
conclusion not based on solid arguments
or science I love how she's suddenly for
science
oh yeah right all right it's okay fine
um we got to get that guy on the show I
think he'd be and he's just a fifth
grade teacher who's putting his butt on
the line to do that because I have no
doubt that he's getting a ton of of hate
on that but good for Dr Phil to even
have that be willing to have that
conversation and I just want to say one
other thing on this before we move on to
the next clip if you're a dude and your
vagina is bleeding you've got a problem
okay
clip that and send it around the
internet
[Music]
thank you